let's show you these pictures from the  garden or should we eat the train  station in Paris and there was an  incident there this morning that  involved a man we believe with a knife  he attacked several people is what we're  told police on the scene very very  quickly indeed and they described him as  having been rapidly neutralized I'm  guessing that means that he was shot  dead by the armed police there in Paris  Gart nor train station uh not sure what  his motives were how many people indeed  were injured or indeed the severity of  those injuries everything looked calm  again now though at Parry Garden or  train station must have been a very  alarming few moments for the commuters  who were going through that very busy  station of course it links the train  under the tunnel here to the UK as well  but as I said it looks pretty calm now  there at the Paris train station we'll  get more information as soon as we can  we